how many of you would seek out a job
that offered hangover leads
or how about a payday off of work if
your team loses a big game or a series
what about a pet bereavement period
sounds too good to be true well some
certainly are but some unique perks are
already being offered by certain
companies
employers today offering more
imaginative job perks in order to
differentiate themselves from other
employers to attract top talent and keep
the talent that they have some employers
already offer paternity leave which is
paid time off to bond with a new pet and
pet bereavement leave matt gauche with
choseaic found half a dozen companies
that offer one or both rover the
nation's largest networkers of dog
sitters and walkers with three days of
paid pet bereavement leave the company
zodix has a soft spot for pets as well
employees who bring home new puppies are
given paid time off a pet store gift
card and a lifetime supply of pet
shampoo for major corporations it makes
sense to attract millennials who are
currently the largest generation in the
workforce and have also become the
largest pet-owning generation
to find out what else people in the job
market would respond to trousaia
commissioned a poll to rank a wish list
of unusual job perks paid celebration
recovery tops america's wish list
followed by hangover leak break up leave
social media detox days premium
subscription to a dating app
compassionately for hard sick sport fans
outlandish job perks may be one way to
attract and retain talent in such
competitive times but gachi says that
employer emphasis on fair pay and pay
equity will be the strongest angle a
study conducted by indeed.com finds
there are currently two jobs for every
candidate and 75 percent of employees
are more likely to apply for a job that
promotes pay transparency